we're supposed to believe that what's
being said is that God the father was
simply revealing something that's always
been the case
who's doing the mental gymnastics with
the textbooks
[Music]
what's up YouTube as always welcome to
the channel today we're kicking off the
next series and we are transitioning
from discussing the gospel of adventism
to an equally as important topic and
that is examining the Jesus of adventism
there is a lot to cover so we will
address it in small bite-sized chunks in
each part we're going to establish
something from scripture followed by an
internal examination of Adventist
teaching in light of that but before
getting into it I want to begin by
looking at the words of Jesus and Paulie
Apostle to establish something of vital
importance in Matthew 24 Jesus speaking
about the last days says the following
for false Christ and false prophets will
arise and perform great signs and
wonders so as to lead astray if possible
even the elect
so regardless of your eschatological
position and your timeline of Matthew 24
the point can be conclusively made that
Jesus clearly warned of false Christ
rising up in the world the Apostle Paul
writing to the churches at Corinth
emphasized the same thing in second
Corinthians 11 1-4 where he writes this
I wish you would bear with me in a
little foolishness do bear with me for I
feel a Divine jealousy for you since I
betrothed you to one husband to present
you as a pure virgin to Christ but I am
afraid that as the serpent deceived Eve
by his cunning your thoughts will be led
astray from a sincere and pure devotion
to Christ for if someone comes and
proclaims another Jesus than the one we
proclaimed or if you receive a different
Spirit from the one you received or if
you accept a different gospel than the
one you accepted you put up with it
readily enough
so Paul had great concern that if
someone came along proclaiming a
different Jesus a different spirit and a
different gospel than the one that he
preached that these Believers would fall
prey to it these statements from both
Jesus and Paul make it Crystal Clear
there are false jesuses out there simply
saying the name Jesus is not enough The
Details Matter so who is the Jesus of
adventism is it the biblical and
historical Christ after all a false
Christ just like a false gospel cannot
save you because neither of them are
real so with that established we need to
establish something else and that is the
true Divinity of Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ is God Almighty the fullness of
the godhead bodily the creator of all
things Yahweh In the Flesh he is not God
the father or the Holy Spirit but is
co-equal and co-eternal alongside them
we will discuss the trinity in the next
series but for all intents and purposes
in this one it's pertinent that we
establish that Jesus Christ is Yahweh
God and I'm going to prove that to you
now from scripture in Isaiah 44 6 God
speaking through is Isaiah says this
says the Lord the king of Israel and his
Redeemer the Lord of hosts I am the
first and I am the last besides me there
is no God he continues building on this
by speaking against idolatry in verses 9
through 20 before then transitioning
into who exactly the one true God is
starting in verse 21 but in verse 24 he
says something foundational he says this
thus says the Lord your Redeemer who
formed you from the womb I am the Lord
who made all things who alone stretched
out the heavens who spread out the Earth
by myself
so Isaiah makes it clear as does
Deuteronomy 6 4 and elsewhere there is
only one true God the Lord Yahweh
speaking of Jesus in Colossians 1 Paul
then says the following
for by him all things were created in
heaven and on Earth visible and
invisible whether Thrones or dominions
or rulers or authorities all things were
created through him and for him
so Isaiah tells us that there's one true
God Yahweh and he alone created
everything Paul tells us that Jesus
created everything thus Jesus Christ is
Yahweh God almighty this is not to the
exclusion of the father and the Holy
Spirit as like I said before we will
cover the trinity in the next series but
it must be understood that Jesus Christ
is Yahweh God he is not a lesser being
he is not a demigod he is not a creature
and Hebrews 13 8 makes it clear that
Jesus Christ is the same yesterday today
and forever he's always been God
Almighty and always will be so with that
established let's start from the
beginning and look back at the Adventist
pre-earth origin story for those that do
not know the Adventist Church teaches
something called the Great controversy
between Jesus and Satan this is the
length through which they read the
entire Bible and it informs all of their
theology they call this lens the great
controversy theme this controversy
supposedly started prior to the creation
of the earth so what was the first
Domino that started this controversy in
Ellen White's Patriarchs and Prophets on
page 37 she writes the following
the exaltation of the Son of God as
equal with the father was represented as
an injustice to Lucifer who it was
claimed was also entitled to reverence
and honor
so considering what we looked at earlier
that Jesus Christ is God Almighty how is
this possible Yahweh was exalted to be
made equal with Yahweh how was the
creator of all things exalted to be made
equal with the father whom he already
possesses equality with the only
explanation for this would be to say
that Jesus is not God Almighty in fact
in the next part we're going to examine
Ellen White saying precisely that but in
sticking with this idea of exaltation
she actually goes on to contradict
herself in the very next paragraph of
Patriarchs and Prophets by saying this
there had been no change in the position
or authority of Christ Lucifer's envy
and misrepresentation and his claims to
equality with Christ had made necessary
a statement of the true position of the
Son of God but this had been the same
from the beginning many of the Angels
were however blinded by Lucifer's
deceptions
so Jesus was exalted to be made equal
with the father but this exaltation was
supposedly only a revealing of something
that was already true but wasn't known
by the rest of Heaven is that what an
exaltation is Christian this is what the
Adventists are going to point you to to
say they don't believe that there was a
change in his position Authority or
honor this was merely a revelation of
something that already was to which
again I ask is that what exaltation
means let's keep examining this she
states the same thing in more detail in
the spirit of Prophecy vol 1 on page 17
she writes
the great Creator assembled the heavenly
host that he might in the presence of
all the Angels confer special honor upon
his son the son was Seated on the throne
with the father and the Heavenly throng
of Holy Angels was gathered around them
the father then made known that it was
ordained by himself that Christ his son
should be equal with himself so that
wherever was the presence of his son it
was as his own presence she continues in
the next paragraph by saying Satan was
envious and jealous of Jesus Christ yet
when all the Angels bowed to Jesus to
acknowledge his Supremacy and high
Authority and rightful rule Satan bowed
with them but his heart was filled with
envy and hatred Christ had been taken
into the special counsel of God in
regard to his plans while Satan was
unacquainted with them he did not
understand neither was he permitted to
know the purposes of God but Christ was
acknowledged Sovereign of Heaven his
power and authority to be the same as
that of God himself
so the father ordained that Jesus would
be exalted to be made equal with himself
he conferred which means granted special
honor unto Jesus that he didn't
previously possess acknowledged him as
the Sovereign of Heaven giving him power
and authority to match his own and we're
supposed to believe that what's being
said is that God the father was simply
revealing something that's always been
the case who's doing the mental
gymnastics with the text folks
furthermore how was Jesus who is Yahweh
not familiar with the special counsels
of God when he is God this places a
layer of division within the godhead
this is not the Jesus of scripture or
history she gives more details in volume
2 of the same book on page 9 where she
writes
the Son of God was next in authority to
the great lawgiver he knew that his life
alone could be sufficient to Ransom
Fallen man he was as of much more value
than man as his Noble spotless character
in exalted office of commander of all
the Heavenly hosts were above the work
of man he was in the express image of
his father not in features alone but in
Perfection of character
again she makes it a point to say that
Jesus did not possess the same Authority
as the father from eternity past but had
this given to him by the father in the
sight of all the Angels if he was next
in Authority that means he did not
possess the same Authority from eternity
past which would mean he isn't Yahweh he
is some sort of a demigod or a lesser
distinct being from the father as if
that wasn't enough she again reiterates
this idea and testimonies for the church
Volume 8 on page 268 where she writes
God is the father of Christ Christ is
the Son of God to Christ has been given
an exalted position he has been made
equal with the father all the councils
of God are open to his son
she plainly states that Jesus was given
an exalted position meaning he did not
possess this prior and this giving is
what made him equal with the father
opening the counsels of God to him this
is not a mere revelation of something
that's always been true the Adventist
Church is in a bind while many sdas are
going to be quick to tell you our
fundamental beliefs state that we
believe Jesus is fully God one has to
get into what exactly they mean by the
word god something we will look at in
the Trinity examination but the same
fundamental beliefs that pay lip service
to Christ being fully God also say that
Ellen White's writings speak with
prophetic Authority their statement of
confidence in the writings of Ellen G
white say that those writings correct
inaccurate interpretations of scripture
you can't have it both ways until Mrs
White's writings are demoted this
Catch-22 will exist so to recap in the
Adventist worldview sin entered the
world through Lucifer's Rebellion where
he then became Satan the accuser and
this started What's called the Great
controversy between Christ and Satan
what was the first Domino to trigger
this controversy the exaltation of Jesus
to be made equal with the Father which
made Lucifer jealous if you've been on
this channel for any amount of time you
know that we have discussed the great
controversy theme and how foundational
it is to the Adventist system without
that first Domino that started this
controversy you don't have a supposed
great controversy let alone a great
controversy theme that all of theology
is to be understood through lastly I
encourage you all to look at the broader
narrative for yourselves which is why
all of the references are in the
description box down below if you found
today's video helpful hit that like
button subscribe and ring the
notification Bell so you can be notified
when content like this is uploaded as
always I'll see you guys around next
time God bless
[Applause]
[Music]
all right